now want you to write down with me a few
the key terms that I alluded to
yesterday and I didn't mention but we
didn't sort of lay them out and define
them okay the first thing that I want to
get in your in your books is the idea of
initial phase we talked about this under
the heading of where do you start
and therefore what equation of motion
would you choose what equation of
displacement right so we noticed you had
basically you kind of had four choices
right you're at this guy this is kind of
your vanilla a simple harmonic motion
right where does he begin where does he
begin time zero he's at the he's at the
origin isn't here like wherever your um
your starting position your site your
center of motion is okay when he starts
moving right which direction does he go
in first
think about what sign looks like which
way did you go because he doesn't go
like any way he goes in a particular
every single time he goes in the
positive direction whichever whatever we
defined that to be up right so this
starts at the origin and their Moo's in
the positive direction okay but maybe we
don't want our motion to do that right
maybe we want our motion to start at the
origin but how I change it if I wanted
to go in the negative direction to start
with at slapping minus sign on the front
wouldn't I that'd still be starting at
zero but then he'd go downwards
immediately and you can see where I'm
going cut you okay what if I said this
okay
where does he begin he begins out well
the actual value would be he begins at a
doesn't he but in terms of describing
this in terms of our motion right number
one he doesn't start at the origin he
starts at one of the ends right which
end does he start at the positive side
right he starts at the positive
extremity and then obviously because
he's at the extremity he has to move in
the other direction that makes sense and
of course I could reverse it if I wanted
to in exactly the same way that I
reversed sign right he's gonna start
down the bottom and immediately gonna
move upwards okay so this idea of
initial phase builds on this by saying
look these starting points here right we
can fine-tune it by adding in an angle
okay
that angle really is a time yeah so that
time there we often call that the
initial phase right so generally we try
to choose one of these four equations to
get an official and initial phase of
zero good just makes the numbers simpler
okay so there's a key idea an idea that
I've already been referring to here you
can guess what do you think this is
referring to I'll give you okay so we
have motion yeah right
what have I been talking about here it's
about where I start me right and where I
go those kinds of things right one of
the critical points or rather I should
take two of their critical points right
are the furthest points you can go right
namely you know if this bar over here
that's that's as far as I can go over
there and this far over here right so
what I mean by that is the extremities
and you'll see that phrase used a lot
you need to know what it's talking about
they'll say how long it is it in between
the time is when you're at the
extremities of motion right okay good
one more important phrase
you can guess it's kind of the opposite
of this it's the center of motion right
now that's my own that's my segue into
talking about you know all of these they
all have the same center of motion
namely of zero the origin
okay but I posed the question to you
yesterday what if we don't want it to be
at zero what if we wanted to oscillate
that's another important word or
fluctuate what if we wanted to oscillate
around somewhere else or slight around 3
or 4 or negative 2 whatever okay we're
going to get some different equations
I'm gonna show the to you and I'm going
to show you by am going through this
table so if you haven't drawn already
two columns and yesterday we talked to
an exponential growth of growth decay
and the way that we modified it
and what resulted from that okay so
think with me standard old exponential
growth or decay for some population okay
if it was growth okay what is the usual
sort of equation we start with a or P
naught right times e to the KT you write
V good there's growth no problem okay
now we knew that if that was your tiny
question this is in terms of time right
you got a corresponding differential
equation for that because you can
differentiate this and because chain
rule right that K the derivative of the
inside function comes out the front you
get K a e to the KT right namely K times
whatever your population is okay good
we've done that to depth right but we
saw that if we wanted to modifiers if we
wanted to modify it okay if for instance
we did not want to have a sort of
approaching zero okay we don't do some
like this we introduce a consonant this
guy okay he would shift things up see
you this or whatever that was okay but
when you differentiate this right what
happens well the cluster it just
disappears right you get this guy but
that's what KP is it it's not K P
because P is something else right in
fact it's K times something else what's
missing the clutter that's missing right
it's very close to the actual population
but it's minus the cluster right and
we've seen all kinds of variations of
this you know if I said minus K outside
of t minus e that means law of cooling
anytime we have some kind of equilibrium
that isn't zero okay so here's my point
you take some tiny question right you
get a differential equation from it if
you've modified it's fine equation
you ought to expect that you modify the
differential equation as well I can now
simplify the regression okay we've
looked at this example X for this
spit right just to take one let's go
anytime that's always going to be my
default okay no we already know what the
difference equation for this is I wrote
it down over there it skips the first
derivative okay because the relationship
between displacement and motion sorry
displacement velocity it's not always
the same depending on what you're saying
cookies but your relationship between
displacement and acceleration is always
the same no matter where you start or
which direction you're going in to begin
with so that's why we called this the
equation okay now if this is the time
equation for regular simple harmonic
motion and this is a differential
equation that results okay what would I
do if I wanted to change the center of
motion at the moment this set
regressions at the origin okay suppose I
wanted to move it to some arbitrary
place elsewhere not the origin okay I'm
gonna call that that place I'm gonna
call it X naught okay and you'll see a
codex a lot a lot right all right let's
rehearse this what happens when I
differentiate this concept of will
vanish right not only will close to
vanish but what you end up over here is
the same velocity equation you get for
this one right so I'm going to skip
straight to acceleration because I think
you can see it right if I've got the
same velocity equation here then what am
I going to get for this acceleration
equation it's gonna be negative and
squared outside off this guy right and
of course I haven't closed it because
it's been differentiated away
disappeared so here's my time equation
for displacement and here's my time
equation for acceleration
I want a differential equation now you
can see what's going on
can't you right I don't have minus N
squared X anymore cuz that's not X this
is X right
so how do I compensate how do I still
have a beautiful acceleration
differential equation you still have a
negative N squared out don't you okay
but in the brackets right what you've
got is not X but X take away X not huh
that looks familiar so I am deliberately
trying to draw the parallel between what
you established here with the
exponential graph you became and what
you seek here when you change the center
evolution you're doing exactly the same
thing I just really need to do it
because through all of them applications
of calculus to the physical world
you just get literally like scores of
equations and it's just easy to confuse
them ok so I want you to see the
parallelism how they relate to each
other